foreign
Diddy and young Miami go Instagram
official on New Year's Eve I need me a
girl to be true to me you know about the
game and know how a dude in me yeah
Diddy once raped about needing a girl
and seems he's got that with young Miami
proving they do go together I feel like
you single where we go together
I'm not laughing we go together now real
bad
okay
whatever you say I like that check out
the couple packing on the PDA as they
ring in the New Year together on a yacht
in St Barts Diddy and Miami dressed to
the nines posing in a variety of sultry
positions sitting down bending over and
even a straddle Miami yeah [ __ ] I'm
from the city
Miami posted some pics on her page too
including a ride on an ATV and a near
kiss between the couple the caption
another 365 days around the world with
you shout out to deity it's about him
tonight the couple made things IG
official just two months after Diddy
welcomed his seventh child a little girl
named Love Sean Combs with another woman
28 year old cyber security specialist
Dana Tran the baby news left fans with a
lot of questions but Miami was quick to
set the record straight at the time she
posted to Instagram I'm nobody side
blank let's just make this clear on this
good Monday she even added a bit of sass
quote did he won't even look half of
y'all's way that's when Diddy entered
the chat I want to get it right be
tweeted in response young Miami is not
my side chick never has been never will
be she's very important and special to
me and I don't play about my shorty walk
I don't discuss things on the internet
and I will not start today you like one
of the realest people I haven't met you
know what I'm saying and you know
authentically yourself
and you know a great mother and you know
a great friend you just have a good time
Diddy and Miami sparked dating rumors
last year and last year on her podcast
Miami cut right to the chase I watch our
relationship status
you missed the egg bag
I'm single you know
I'm single but I'm dating I'm just
taking my time with life so what we use
we date
we dating
we go have dates
and we friends
okay you go to Exotic locations
we have great times we go to strip clubs
Church
church church
I'm gonna take you to church
I love that and while those yacht picks
aren't exactly giving holy we love to
see a happy couple
[Music]